at what point did you know basically the
moment that we met like I think I've
said this before but when I was
proposing I made this video for her kind
of going through our whole relationship
our families were all inside the house
and I was waiting on the beach and she
went inside the house they surprised her
and she was confused and they were like
watch this video and they all watched
the video together and the end slide was
me basically being like you know but
I've known the whole time and then it
was a screenshot of a of a message that
I sent to my friend in Australia and I
was like the second time that we had
hung out so this is like three days
after we met or something like that and
I was like I met my wife oh my God and
then it was like come down to the beach
like I want to ask you a question that
was like the light the last thing on the
thing but so like that's just proof that
like I basically knew like right away